uh last topic of the day we got in
trouble earlier not really but we did
fill in the blanks and we only got the
one topic talking about taysom hill so
we've got three more that we want to go
ahead and finish up so we can say we did
our job for this monday
jacoby brissette says he's just doing
his job when it comes to all the
quarterback rumors involving the colts
the blank will employ jacoby brissette
in 2020.
right now i'm still going to go with the
colts
right now i'm going to go with the colts
as him being a really high-priced backup
quarterback now there's another great
example of why did you throw all that
money out there did you have to throw
that much out there to him you know this
is what i don't understand about owners
in the quarterback market right now and
i just i don't i think we're overdoing
it but you know i'd look at his current
cap charge and the things he's dealing
with there
and i just have a hard time thinking
that they're going to be able to trade
jacoby percent away because some team's
gonna look at him as a starter and then
also pay him what is it 15 million
dollars a year mike right i mean that's
about the money he's expecting to make i
got to pull it up again i got it here i
left it up the page i was on there by by
accident but that to me is the big thing
like i don't think they're getting rid
of jacoby per set unless they pay some
of the salary as well
yeah they owe him 8 million plus in a
guaranteed roster bonus and there's a
six million dollar salary on top and i
think he's going to play for the colts i
think they're going to keep him and
they're going to supplement him with
somebody else yes who's making as much
or less than jacoby beset and then
combined you know that's your
quarterback budget but i think they want
to see
uh if brissett can turn it around frank
reich is a believer and i still think
that if they can get nick foles and if
the jaguars pay part of his salary uh or
if they can get a good trade deal then
maybe they take falls off the jaguars
hands and the jaguars by all appearances
want to go forward with gardner minshew
that could be a win-win and then you'll
let falls in brissette compete i agreed
i could totally see that you're right i
mean the dead money and what they're
gonna pay him and all of that just
doesn't make sense i mean if he stays on
the team they give them 15.8 million
dollars if they cut them it's still
gonna cost 12.5 million dollars so for
that the three million dollar difference
i would just say colts you just keep
them and then see what else you can do
from from there on out so it'll be
interesting i do think there'll be some
teams that will call and be interested i
would think like hey teams that you know
maybe the new england patriots the
tennessee titans the houston texans all
who of course know people in new england
who drafted them originally and have a
same
vision of what they want their backup
quarterback to be i think jacobi percent
will have a market like that but i just
don't know if ultimately anybody's going
to trade anything away from them and pay
them that money
watch the parcels connections too sure
you're right i said it's very close with
yourselves so he may be twisting some
arms out there to get somebody to take
him teddy bridgewater is close with
parcells as well yeah and i mean who
knows depending upon
i don't think the saints can afford this
but you know they need a veteran who can
run the saints offense if drew brees is
injured because that's not taysom hill
and if teddy leaves i think brissette
will be too expensive but but
pittsburgh steelers i'd be calling the
colts right because i'd go okay if ben
gets hurt again i don't want to just
watch my season go down the drain with
the guys we have and we feel like we're
a talented team that would be a team i
would go man jacoby bersetta would make
sense for him and the steelers would
make sense for them too to protect
themselves like a bridgewater did for
brees in the saints this past year that
would be another team that you know i
thought about filling in the blank with
ultimately i went with the colts but
those were the teams that were going
through my head
all right next up aaron rodgers says he
understands the packers could use a
first round pick on a quarterback but
would prefer more immediate help if you
were brian gooda koontz you would in
round one draft a blank draft a
difference maker that's all i care about
i mean ultimately i want to say a wide
receiver but you know even if it's a big
time defensive tackle bill you know
draft something yeah i would draft
something that's going to help my team
right now you know you've said it right
many times here over the last year
and this is real and this is the reality
i think of the future of the nfl we're
seeing every year
four or five really talented guys come
in the nfl at the quarterback position
you don't need to panic and go oh man
aaron rodgers only has four years left
we need to draft a quarterback no you
don't he's got at least four years left
make the team better they need some big
time play makers they do need an aj
green or a number one receiver in the
draft whatever it may be you know they
they need something like that or another
offense alignment or interior d tackle
like i said but i don't want to see it
wasted on a quarterback i wouldn't do
that
offensive linemen in round one are
always uh not and defensive lineman
anybody other than skill position
players aren't viewed as sexy because
everybody's looking for their next
fantasy football stand out but i would
go with an offensive lineman brian
balaga likely not going to be back and
uh i would want to keep aaron rodgers
protected but i know that aaron rodgers
sat for three years but the only reason
they drafted aaron rodgers is because
bret they didn't know what the hell
brett favre was gonna do every year he's
talking about i may retire may retire
may retire well they had to protect
themselves rogers fell into their laps
so they took him yes and he sat for
three years until they finally
encouraged brett favre to get the hell
out because they wanted to go forward
with rogers that's right we have no
inkling of that i mean rogers makes
comments i heard him make a comment on
friday on that wisconsin radio show he
plans on playing for a long a long time
so when he says that i don't think we're
even in the you know last four years
conversation here i think this is a guy
that's looking to go to 40 or somewhere
41 or 42. he takes care of his body and
and i you know i don't think he's going
to lose rpms on his arm or anything like
that so yes i would not rush to the
quarterback conversation if i'm guten
coost yet
he's 36 years old he is signed through
2023
they wouldn't have given him that giant
contract
that they did if they if they didn't
think he was gonna play for a while and
uh yeah i think he's gonna be there and
they shouldn't waste a draft pick on a
position where they have a starter who's
going to be there for a long time they
can find a backup and they need to use
that pick on an impact player and i
would say offensive lineman all right
last one the cardinals the jets and the
texans have inquired about trent
williams out of those three teams the
blank need trent williams the most well
i'd probably go with the cardinals i
think if i was going to look at any of
those three i mean
they all can use them certainly i think
the texans are probably the one i look
at that like least could use him i mean
they did draft two offensive alignment
early and first rounder and i'm max
sharping i can't remember if he was a
second or third rounder and of course
they traded you know for laramie tunzel
as well so i look at them and go okay
they're okay the cardinals i just go you
know and the jets are in this
conversation as well but the cardinals i
mean you got a guy like kyla murray as
we've talked about he's special he
really is and you know you got a guy
like trent williams he's really special
too he's a hall of fame left tackle
i mean he's really like slam dunk
doesn't matter who you put over there he
can handle him by himself and yeah i
think that would be uh a great addition
to that football team you know they
could have him attack a left tackle and
then you know have a guy like dj
humphreys who's talented or whatever at
right tackle or whatever they want to do
they they can move it around
when i saw the texans were interested my
first thought is are they going to trade
laramie tunsil for trent williams
and get maybe get back some of what they
gave up to get tunsle right i think
i think it's a good thought both of them
i thought it was odd too i'm with you i
did not quite get that either i i was
with you i'm with you i was like well
what are they gonna do they could move
laramie tunzel or to right tackle or are
they yes or are they trying to think
about hey we'll give you a tonsil and
just give us trent williams and we'll
make a trade that way and then we'll
give trent williams a new contract i
don't know but uh yeah i thought that
was a little peculiar too
yeah and part of the problem the texans
pulled the trigger on that trade last
year gave up a lot to get tunsle and
receiver kenny stills and didn't sign
him to a new contract then and there all
the leverage is with tons
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports